for comic-con we hired one of the
lesser-known droids from Star Wars as a
production assistant kind of throw him a
bone I'm talking about our 5d four he's
been here all week and he's been working
his butt off he's been working very hard
he made copies for us yeah very good at
that he fetched our executive producer
Jeff Ross's dry cleaning he cleaned my
dressing room toilet yeah he's been
Andy's personal assistant all week so
good yeah r5 you are a magician my
friend and r54 has written half our
monologue jokes this week he's very
talented let's get him out here
thank you thanks for helping us out this
week are fives all right you know when
you think about it RFID for it you've
been doing very well you know when you
consider that you're a minor Droid
character from Star Wars you've come a
long way r2d2 he's doing great that's
not fair our fights been doing an
awesome job all week
[Music]
that's terrible no come back
show that bar five come back
[Applause]
[Applause]
he got he got to that window fast yeah I
know very quick and when his head came
off it looked like a washtub I thought
it looked pretty convinced okay hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy japanese pornography